here is our vision we want to
democratize the marketplace make it easy
and affordable for everybody to invest
in the brands they love and that
includes IPOs and we include IPOs by the
way because that epitomizes the elite
that we're trying to change that is
initial public offerings that's the
first time a couple company goes public
those are always available to the big
institutions and their largest clients
and we want to break that paradigm we
want to destroy that paradigm we want to
show the world that there is a level
playing field and we're doing that
through our pursuit of making IPOs
available to everybody
Obama raised more money in 2008 on
investments on donations under $200 then
McCain did from everybody and you know I
heard President Clinton saying the
Katrina was the first natural disaster
ever that raised over a billion dollars
in donations and the average donation
was how much what do you think oh you're
a tough crowd 60 $60 to get to a billion
dollars it sounded like he was talking
about Lowell Three's business model
right a billion dollars raised that's
the power of the crowd that is the power
of the Internet and really if you strip
out the economics for a second what
we're saying is people that have been
devalued where capital formation belongs
the big the crowd allows us to bring
power back to the individual because in
aggregate in large forms individuals
together can be significantly
influential significantly impactful from
an economic perspective before Lowell
three the most amount of IPOs that could
most amount of participants in a single
IPO that could ever be done was 60,000
60,000 accounts and that was General
Motors when they did their IPO General
Motors asked
to do two million they wanted everybody
to participate to celebrate and it just
couldn't be done for regulatory reasons
and for technology reasons and so we
worked and we can now do 10 million not
60,000 but 10 million in one I P o start
to think of the numbers 10 million
people putting $100 in 10 million people
putting you know five hundred dollars
that's that's a strong powerful machine
and it's made up of people not big
institutions matter of fact specifically
we don't sell to big institutions you
have a one requirement at two by Sokolow
3 a social security number a beating
heart and it's so awesome because when
you think about the barriers to
democratize in the market when you think
about what our objectives are easy
affordable fee free that's what's going
to build little 3 into a powerhouse at
the end of the day we want to make a
difference at the end of the day we want
our life to count for something and so
if we can build a company that can make
a difference that can really have a
vision that's important and you can
align along with that some comadre and
the chance for your employees to do well
as well then you've got the right
algorithm and that's what we have at
Lowell 3 and that's what you saw in that
first quadrant we don't talk with that
same grandiosity we don't talk with that
same sense of emotion other than when we
get to the users where we want to also
express emotion the stock rewards is so
very cool stock rewards is actually the
ability to gift stock to be able to gift
stock to people you care about and we're
starting off by actually having
companies gifted they'll gift it for
surprise and delight to the really good
customers and or they'll gift it in
return for a promotion buy $100 worth of
product get $25 to start why would a
company want to do that because rather
than discounting their brand when they
do a promotion given gifting stock is
really
brand friendly and it creates loyalty
there's a loyalty effect to ownership
when you own something you care much
more about it if you own coca-cola stock
would you ever drink Pepsi you know
would you let your friends drink Pepsi
the social IPL platform that I'm going
to show you today that's a thing that
rocks because it's just never been done
before there's been precisely three IPOs
that have ever been crowd-sourced we've
done them all and we've done it between
October of last year and in February
this year
with our product you're going to be able
to tell all of your customers all of
your employees all of your affiliates
and partners that you matter you helped
us build this brand and we recognize
that and you matter to us so much that
we're going to reserve some of our IPO
stock and make it available accessible
to all of you at the same price as Wall
Street you don't take a risk just
because you enjoy risks
I mean you adjust it you think it
through and some things when people say
it's a dumb idea it really is a dumb
idea you know but but this we knew what
it would do
we knew the differentiation this was
central to our vision to make it easy
and affordable for everybody it's the
first time it's ever been done in the
history of securities are the biggest
obstacles were getting through the SEC
and right now as with any disruptive
company status quo is always going to be
your competitor and if I had to answer
that in the shortest way possible I
would say our biggest competitor is
compromised every single day the status
quo wants to make it easier for you as
long as you compromise and give up a
little bit that edge your path will
become easier and we have to be able to
have the strength of our vision and
clarity of our vision to say yes when
it's a good compromise but if it's a
principle we say no there's a protection
of the way things are which is
institutions and a fear over what we
want to do what
put power to a lot more people but the
idea of democratization the idea of love
on the playing field
how many people can actually take a
really hard stance against that we have
90 percent of the people in our platform
have never sold stock they just buy and
they hold and they buy more and they
hold 64 percent give us authorization to
debit their credit card or their bank
account and they buy every single month
that's that's that's when I say change
in the world and bringing power for it
everybody in this room into the market
that's the way it should be then
companies can start to have
dependability on their capital sources
and they're not worried about quarter
quarter type earnings where somebody's
going to dump them for whatever reason
or worse yet which head spun owns them
and what percent is going to be shorting
them we have a very strong culture in
our company and it goes with the three
eyes
the first one is integrity and that's
not optional
we we don't want anybody to ever feel
that too politic or lie we want people
to be candid honest at all times and it
made a mistake who cares it been a
problem who cares I mean that's how you
get velocity of execution and there's
nobody in the world that wants to work
with somebody that they can't trust you
know it's funny in our company I say
raise your hand if you've got kids and
most of people do and I say now raise
your hand if you tell your kids I want
you to be deceptive I want you to be
political I want you to take sides I
want you to play mom against dad you
know no you tell your kids honesty
period and what does that mean to us at
Lowell 3 that means the ability to make
a decision admission against your own
personal interests so number one
integrity number two innovation I want
everything that we do to reflect the
world of innovation and that means that
everybody has got a voice all ideas are
good when we end up deciding the path to
go we narrow but it doesn't stop the
conversations and it doesn't stop the
ideation at our company what you'll hear
people saying all the time is
we get to invent every single day and
the third thing the third eye is
interdependence and and that is there is
no one superstar who wants to work at a
company where there's a superstar or two
superstars
the truth is interdependence is what
wins when everybody knows that the
person beside them is important to the
success of the company that's team that
creates team and and then when you're
going to some area of the office and you
hear somebody talking to somebody else
about you know elevating the game I love
that so reputation to me I don't think
reputation is built by you know kind of
the forensics and details of what you
say and how you do it
I think reputation long-term reputation
is built on what you do and the
consistency in which you do that